welcome everyone my name is Ryan
Williams I'm the president of the
Claremont Institute and I have also the
honor of being the publisher of the
Claremont Review of Books I want to
thank you all for joining us this
evening for a discussion of nationalism
and sovereignty the occasion for that
discussion is your mazzani's new book
the virtue of nationalism I know Matt
and I at least have talked publicly
about nationalism is a very afraid of
topic these days I think Matt and I have
always taken the perspective that in
America nationalism is a particular
thing and maybe somewhat different than
European nationalism
it's a nationalism we think rooted in
the Declaration of Independence and so
less rooted in the blood and soil
old-world notions of nationalism I think
you are in your book covers a lot more
ground than that and he may even
disagree with that a bit
I had agree with it a bit so we thought
this was a wonderful occasion for a
discussion about this topic so let me
just introduce our panelists and then
we'll get into our speakers yarn will
lead us off Colin and then Matt will
have a final word and then we'll have
plenty of time for discussion so your
amazonia's president of the Herzl
Institute and his books include our
topic today the virtue of nationalism as
well as the Jewish state the struggle
for Israel's soul dr. hezonia is written
for The Wall Street Journal national
affairs and National Review among other
publications Colin do it to his left his
professor in the SLAR school of policy
and government at George Mason
University and the author of the Obama
doctrine American grand strategy
hardline the Republican Party stream and
u.s. foreign policy since World War two
and reluctant Crusaders power culture
and change in American Christmas
strategy dr. doback is a prolific writer
for both scholarly and journals and the
public prints and most importantly from
my perspective that he's a frequent
contributor to the Claremont
books I say that as much out of a sense
of gratitude as some promotion I promise
you and then finally we'll hear from
Matt Spaulding Matt's associate vice
president and Dean of educational
programs here at the Kirby Center
he's also the author of the excellent
book we still hold these truths
rediscovering our principles reclaiming
our future and he's the executive editor
of the heritage guide to the
Constitution he's also written to find
books on George Washington I I encourage
you to check them out and then also most
importantly for my purposes again he's a
senior fellow of the Claremont Institute
so please join me in welcoming our
scholars and let's get into it
[Applause]
you're
and Matt and there's so many great
people worked on while organizing this
and thank you all for coming out well
let let's let's begin with blood and
soil I don't think that I've heard the
expression blood and soil used so
frequently anywhere in the world as
among American intellectuals and it's
it's kind of it's kind of one of these
buzz phrases I'm not I'm not sure how
many people know where it comes from but
basically blood and soil is a is a
German version of a very general
phenomenon the the general phenomenon is
that we look around the world not just
the last few hundred years but going all
the way back into antiquity and we see
the word nation being used and we see
things that look to us like nations but
these nations have different traditions
and different different views of things
and some of them claim that you know
some of them claim that that blood and
soil is is the key and some of them
claim that that the Declaration of
Independence is key and others claim
that that that the Torah or the Bible is
key and and you can just keep going
what's wonderful about nations I mean
you can say there's all sorts of bad
things about them what's wonderful about
them is their intrinsic diversity the
there are all different experiments
different ways in which human societies
try out being human some of them are
terrible and some of them are good some
of them have things to teach the whole
world and some of them maybe less so the
reason that the subject is so
interesting today obviously is because
there's been a you know just in the last
few years in America in the UK Italy
Eastern Europe Israel India and Japan
and and beyond
the free world has seen a sharp turn in
the direction of thinking about
reconstructing or returning to a
construction of the political order
which is based on nations which is based
specifically on the independence of
Nations which means that nations each
one of them would should be allowed to
express its own constitutional and
religious and legal traditions without
being interfered with from the outside a
very very very few of these nations
historically have spoken in terms of
blood and soil as I say each one has
their own approach but that doesn't mean
that we as members of the the
anglo-american tradition or the Jewish
tradition or any other tradition that we
necessarily would look at at each of
these nationalisms and love them we
might not we might look at some of them
and say wow you know I think that's
appalling
but some of them we would look upon in
admiration and the the argument that the
Nationalists are advancing if I can sort
of put it in kind of a general view the
argument the Nationalists make is that
the world is better off and this is a
principled argument it's not not simply
an emotional expression a principled
argument the world is better off if it's
governed in this way that nations are
allowed their independence and their
freedom they're allowed to determine
their own course now why is this so
important well it wouldn't be so
important if it weren't for the fact
that for the last generation this simp
seemingly simple intuitive idea well
known in the anglo-american tradition
going all the way back to the Hebrew
Bible this idea has become Anathem it's
become detested it's become hated
specifically among educated elites at
least for a generation at least for at
least since 1989 since the fall of the
Berlin Wall maybe earlier but least
since then if you take a look at the
major political parties in the United
States in the UK and
across Europe the major political
parties have been united in saying
something different what have they been
saying they've been saying that actually
peace and prosperity will come to the
world best and most easily if there is a
single set of rules rule-based
international order is some people like
to say some people call it liberal
internationalism if there's one set of
rules one set of values which is going
to be determined to apply to the whole
world and somebody usually the American
armed forces with token assistance from
Europe somebody is going to impose that
that's astonishing that this idea could
go for a generation without there being
kind of an explosive debate about it
because it implicit in it is a view that
used to be called imperialism going back
to Roman times but you know the the
medieval church or the the Islamic
caliphate or the ancient Babylonians or
Assyrians all had this idea peace and
prosperity will come to the world if we
impose order if we suppress violence if
we eliminate the dissent and create a
single order for the world in the early
90s there were Americans who said the
fight against the Soviet Union is over
we won let's go home and let's take care
of America because it needs it people
like Irving Kristol or Jean Kirkpatrick
but those voices were swept aside and
you know if it had turned out well then
maybe we would be living happily in a
liberal liberal universal Empire but it
didn't turn out well and in my book I
argue that it couldn't have turned out
well because no one actually knows
enough to be able to govern the entire
world and when they try then you get at
best these terrible scenes like we see
the Germans trying to govern Greece by
remote control or or the Italians
deciding who their finance minister is
going to be in some kind of a
Vito from from Brussels comes and
dictates no no that's not an appropriate
Finance Minister
so Italy's not an independent country
anymore in my book I argue that the the
reason that we should want a a world of
free nations is all there a number of
reasons but the first and foremost and
foremost is is the issue of freedom the
great political theorist Imran davit
tell from these the the the 1700s and
known today is one of the founders of
international law he advanced the theory
that the reason for the balance of power
the reason for the diffusion of power
among different senator Sanders of
government in in Europe at the time or
in the world is in order to preserve
freedom the whole reason that we go
through the exercise of diffusing power
internationally said is so that no state
should have sufficient power in order to
be able to dictate the law to all the
others that's the entire goal of
international relations as far as Vidal
is concerned we know this argument from
domestic politics that's the reason that
the anglo-american tradition has a
[Music]
diffusion of power among competing
branches of government because we know
that if there's only one then that's
going to tend towards tyranny the same
thing internationally now that people
can reasonably argue that doesn't mean
the fact that you have diffusion of
power among nations
well it might assured diversity it might
assure competition it might even assure
freedom but it doesn't but but then it
would be a national freedom because it
doesn't guarantee that every single one
of these nations would have the kinds of
limited government and individual
freedoms that we are so associate with
the anglo-american tradition and that's
absolutely true
it's simply true when you decide that
you're not going to dictate the law to
the entire earth that means as I said
before that sometimes they're going to
be nations that are going to do things
that you don't like but notice the
following I think crucial point the only
place historically that we know of where
limited government
and individual freedoms have been
developed is in national states
independent national states the
Netherlands England Scotland Switzerland
the United States and others there is no
example of an empire in which you gather
together the the will to conquer the
whole world and then impose a certain
rule on everybody and then miraculously
it turns out that what you've imposed is
individual liberties and liberty and
limited government forget about it
Napoleon tried that right millions of
people died if anybody wants to argue
that that was good I'm willing to take
them on okay a terrible a terrible
vicious imperialism but in the name of
liberalism in the name of liberal values
finally I think that it's that it ended
in addition to this crucial point that
that we we only know of of democracy and
limited government and civil liberties
flourishing and national states in
addition to that point I think that you
also need to consider today especially
in America where where tolerance is
going surely everyone's noticed that
that America today is a far less
tolerant society than any of us can
remember from as far back as we can
remember
I mean I'm not saying that there hasn't
been progress on certain issues but
today I mean who's not afraid to say
what they think you know I mean it's
really terrifying and I think that we
should try to imagine where is this
coming from
and I have a proposal in the book I
propose that it's coming from the
movement of elites especially but really
of the public in the direction of a
Universalist imperialism now it's
complicated because we know the marxist
universalism right that we call
progressives or the left we know that
they want to take over the world we know
that they think there's only one one
truth we're familiar with that but what
about the the Universalist liberals
they're not Marxists all they talk about
is
and freedom freedom freedom is the
centerpiece I find those people also
many of my closest friends included I
mean really people have known for many
many years in the last generation
they've turned in the direction of
saying well we know what truths are
appropriate for the whole world in fact
I can just give you the answers I can
write you a constitution for any country
in the world I don't have any problem
with engaging in in military adventurism
I'm going to bomb civilian centers in
order to eliminate government's that I
think are not appropriate now if if we
were talking about Nazi Germany all
right then all of us would think you
should bomb Nazi Germany but what if
you're not talking about Nazi Germany
what if you're talking about cases that
are much more complicated some of my
friends are too willing to use these
kinds of operations in order to impose
their view of the way countries should
run all over the world and we've seen
all sorts of examples of that I think it
hasn't turned out well for America and I
don't think it's turned out well for
those countries either again if someone
wants to argue with me that Yugoslavia
is in good shape today or Iraq or Libya
let's go I don't think it works where's
the intolerance coming from I think the
intolerance is coming from a state of
mind
especially among our intellectuals
seeping into our politics and then out
to the public a state of mind that says
I know the answers for the whole world
just giving me the power and I'll take
care of it and I think that corrupts
liberals just as much as it corrupts
Marxists in fact it would corrupt
anybody and what we need is a
conservatism a traditional
anglo-american conservatism or something
like it which is willing to say I think
my way of life is the best but I'm not
willing to go and send troops to impose
it on the rest of the world it I think
it's the best but no one knows enough to
know for sure and I'm not going to take
that responsibility
thank you call thank you
well it's a terrific book and I urge you
to buy it buy it twice it's it is the
single best argument that I've seen in
many years for the very simple powerful
notion that there really is no
alternative to the nation state as the
best political unit in which free people
can experiment with constitutional forms
of self-government and you might think
this is obvious the Ferrier of fact that
that's controversial is amazing I mean
it shows you the changes in liberal
thought over time and that's why this is
such an important book so it's it's it's
a great read it's very engaging I also
like the fact that he defended
nationalism not patriotism because
anybody can do that
but nationalism specifically I thought
that was a kind of a courageous move
much of the historical account is
persuasive as urine points out nations
historically have not come together
because of social contract theory for
the most part they've come together
because groups and tribes aggregate
that's that's the historical reality
he's also right I think in a sort of
withering account of the international
hate campaign against Israel Israel and
he's right that there is a kind of
liberal imperialism that has sometimes
misled Western countries especially in
the post Cold War era and that's been a
bipartisan so these are a number of
strengths of the book but if you had
asked me here just to say the ways in
which I agreed with him that would be
boring and I'm sure that's why you
didn't it's not why you asked me so I
will I will raise a few polite questions
and they mostly have to do with the
issue of American nationalism
nationalism specifically which is sort
of my primary interest it is challenging
to develop a global theory of
nationalism right because there are
different kinds of nationalism it seems
to me Venezuelan nationalism is not the
same as Russian nationalism is not the
same as American nationalism American
nationalism in particular is democratic
not authoritarian and I my understanding
my my study in the
to me that going back to the founding
the American experience has been to
emphasize American national sovereignty
but at the same time hold out long-term
possibilities for the expansion of
popular self-government and this was not
just Thomas Jefferson
it was the founders as a whole
Washington Adams Hamilton so this was
this was a broadly who believe then you
get debates between the founders and
throughout American history as to how
exactly to do it and it's true that many
prominent Americans and factions and
parties over the years have said we
don't need to do it necessarily through
military intervention we can do it by
example that's quite right and if after
all the founders didn't have the
capacity for the kinds of massive
military interventions overseas that
Americans have engaged in more recently
so there was a kind of tradition in the
19th century which was consensual and
bipartisan which was we do hope for the
spread of Republican forms of government
and we preserve American national
sovereignty uncontroversial it seems to
me that Woodrow Wilson comes off a
little easy in your arms account because
I've learned from Claremont that Wilson
was something of a revolutionary on
domestic affairs but I also think he was
on foreign affairs he he represents the
break from the founders on foreign
policy and it's not simply because he
proposed permanent commitments in Europe
and in other continents it's because he
really had a kind of project of global
governance it's true he spoke about
national self-determination and he
believed in it as a way of dismantling
European empires but after all he did
propose a project in the form of the
League of Nations that involved serious
secession session of American
sovereignty US senators understood this
which is exactly why they blocked it
those were Universal binding commitments
and the American public and the Senate
wasn't ready to accept it now ever since
Wilson I think American conservatives
have sort of wrestled with how to
respond to Wilson he's the granddaddy of
liberal internationalism over the past
century the initial response of
conservatives to say we reject him Ryan
by the 50s leading conservatives like
William F Buckley said we will continue
to preserve American sovereignty however
we think there are some very severe
challenges that are going to the Soviet
Union and international communism are
going to require us to play a role in
the world that we previously didn't play
we're going to have to make alliances
we're gonna have to build up our
military we're gonna have to have bases
and military intervention overseas that
was Buckley National Review mainstream
movement conservatism starting in the
50s so there's been a debate on the
right and internally as well and as
Doran pointed out beginning in the 90s
there were there was a fragmentation in
multiple points of view and you know
intelligent people can disagree on this
what's been so interesting the last few
years is that I think all of the
previous orthodoxies from the 90s have
just blown wide open we agree on this
right and it's obvious that there was a
kind of neo wilsonian project in the
post Cold War era in both parties
whether it was in Iraq or whether it was
the Clinton version or whether it was
the Obama version that really went off
track it was seen by a significant chunk
of the American population is basically
a failure and and for good reason so we
I think we actually agree on that
however the question is what would it
mean to come home I mean I absolutely
agree we should revise and adjust and
discard some of the more unnecessary
accretions of the liberal international
project over the years I have no problem
for example
exiting from the Paris agreements right
but then when you get to the core
alliances and commitments you know
Britain Japan our partnership with
Israel do we really want to dismantle
this I I don't I mean I'm interested in
hearing the arguments for and against
what I think we have we have a sort of
we still have a set of commitments and
alliances that in my opinion are worth
having even once we even once we get rid
of that neo wilsonian gibberish that
sort of has accumulated over the years
and this brings me back to the nature of
American nationalism going back to the
founding which is that if American
nationalists and American founders
believe that all men are created equal
this is going to have a foreign policy
implication it doesn't mean we have to
meddle in every single case overseas but
it does mean for example that a u.s.
president has the right to go to
nations as the president did last year
and point out particularly egregious
violations on the part of a regime like
North Korea right now what I'd like to
know from your on whose book I thought
was terrific is does the president have
that right or does national sovereignty
on a global scale insulate even the
worst dictatorships from this kind of
criticism you know is there any
distinction between national sovereignty
for democracies on the one hand and
authoritarian governments of the worst
sort on the other and if not then how is
that consistent with the principles of
the American Founding and of the kind of
nationalism they embraced thank you well
you yarn thank you for being here and
Colin as well and oversee our friends to
the Claremont Institute so thank you all
for coming
this is I like I like your book we've
we've talked before he's right to focus
on the sovereignty question I agree the
the the question of nationhood is or the
nation-state is at the core of it and
his work on on describing the problems
of the modern nation-state about
globalism and Cosmopolitan's been post
nationalism and all the other isms
involved in that is very good I'd like
to focus on this question about the
nature of sovereignty its how much some
fun couple things you made because seems
to me that there's some interesting
questions there that it's very important
that we get right so we don't get them
right we might push off in the wrong
direction
let me make a distinction between the
kind of the old sovereignty and the new
sovereignty towards the old sovereignty
which say the sovereignty of the the old
world the ancient world was he who had
the force made all the rules right which
is why in in most of the world in most
of our history we lived in a despotism
or a tyranny or you lived in a situation
where there is a divine claim to rule
you well there was a king or or that
might be
this becomes especially acute when you
get to Judaism but then especially
Christianity which creates a problem for
these things these growing's things
which were increasingly would come the
states or the nation-state because now
you've got a conflict between the City
of God in the city of man and how do you
resolve this well we know in most of
Europe they can't figure this out and we
end up having a lot of Wars and a lot of
people kill each other but this is one
of the questions that the Americans
especially at least the practical level
not the theoretical level with the prat
level figure out how to solve to a to a
large degree and they do so precisely
because they define a new idea of
sovereignty which in turn is based on a
different idea of legitimacy which we're
all kind of alluded to here which we see
most famously in the Declaration of
Independence which itself is a wonderful
discussion of sovereignty it talks about
we are one people and this people is
going to separate from another people
and assume as station according to what
the laws of nature and nature's God but
how do they define themselves to the
people what is that that gives them a
claim of legitimacy such that they can
declare their independence well it's
that all men are created equal and they
are endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable egde it emit based
on the claim of consent which is to say
that in the declaration dependence you
get precisely the the the mix of what we
have oftentimes confused
it's a discussion of universals truths
said to be self-evident but also
particulars right universals in a
particular nation or a particular nation
that's dedicated to universals there's
no contradiction
at all in the same breath they talk
about civilization and barbarism and why
the tyrant is not fit to be the king of
a free people but it's always about a
particular people a particular nation in
this particular place which is say the
founders weren't vulgar vulgar realists
on the one hand but they also weren't
utopian idealist either and they
actually spent a lot of time criticizing
the utopians it's about principle and
practice it's about the balance of the
two of them are as it says in the
Declaration prudence will dictate or as
Washington's farewell address our
interests guided by justice the
practical is never separated from the
universal and the universal is never
understood other than in the context of
the practical that's a different way of
looking at sovereignty it seems to me
the founders were on the one had modern
they favored Liberty limited government
religious liberty which of course is a
very modern concept especially if you
compare you to the ancient world but
there are a many ways closer to a
classical understanding of politics
politics grows there the family the
household the village the city but it's
culminates in the city the regime of
living well according to some purpose
some principle some organizing
principles Lincoln said and for the
Americans as constitutional
self-government so what is all this what
does that mean why do i why do I bring
it up this way it seems to me that to
jump to current current discussions what
Trump has done in the Trump
administration that Trump presidency in
the Trump campaign is it's revealed a
lot of things it's like pulling the
curtain back it's clearly revealed the
left is about wills power
we talked about that a great length but
it's also revealed a lot about
conservatism or what we have long
thought as conservatism and conservative
American become kind of doctrinal and
rigid and stiff and not capable of
thinking prudentially the way the
founders would understand that so it's
good to get back to fundamentals but
thinking that through and trying to
define what that concern should be it
should be is is is very important
our argue that the the the initial model
which was kind of trying to fuse the
libertarianism conservatism and
traditionalism never really worked right
you can't actually fuse things it's it's
it's a temporary date on the question is
are there any underlying principles
underneath that and I think part of that
is because conservatism has never been
completely comfortable with America on
the one hand libertarianism is always
about individuals they're very
interested in utility in an efficiency
more than they are with justice but
traditional stay on the other hand are
always very uncomfortable with rights
and rights are always universals and as
soon as you're gonna the question of
rights it's the French Revolution and
the end of the world and so they spend a
lot of their time thinking about other
things and trying to find other
traditions and they used to usually
point to Trish ins outside of America
and so they talk about Burke Great
Lengths that's Russell Clark famously
did searching for order as if we don't
have one so I think we need a deeper
better effusion ISM and I think it's
actually right here before us I think
the great success of the American
Founding which is neither a kind of it's
not blood and soil depending on how we
want to use those terms it's not
Universal liberalism it's an idea of
rights individual rights but they're
grounded in nature it's this tradition
but it's guided by justice that
combination of things I think is what
conservatives ought to be conserving and
trying to think a lot about and I guess
I would be concerned that we sometimes
in different camps of the isms of
conservatism decide that the other is is
unacceptable and as a result we don't
really have a deeper and more stronger
notion of what it is we ought to be
conserving and I think that's the most
important thing to ultimately understand
so with that we can have some questions
excellent thank you Matt first I just
want to provide some opportunity for
intra panel discussion I did want to
insert one thing that I a point of
injustice on my part from the beginning
I just wanted to thank Spalding and the
Kirby Center for for hosting here
tonight this wonderful venue and for
co-sponsoring with Claremont in your
death this is a great event thank you
with that I think you're I want to give
you a chance to respond to both Colin
and Matt and maybe particularly Colin's
discussion of what exactly what exactly
and in a world
Riaan fused with the virtues of
nationalism what role would an empire
live liberty half in other words what
the Trump at the UN sort of thing or for
that matter Reagan at the UN
what role does that have in world
affairs and then to take up Matt's point
what do you make of his argument which I
largely subscribe to if not wholly this
sort of transformation nationalism that
occurred at the American Founding which
was dealing both with the transformation
of the question of national Allegiance
and Universal allegiance brought on by
the right
Christianity and also at the same time
providing a nicer amalgam of liberalism
but also with a due regard to local time
place circumstances and a notion of
national conceptions of defense and
justice with Matt I very much admire the
America Americans and American
traditions and yet at the same time I'm
very uncomfortable and this is probably
what you were alluding to uncomfortable
with the with establishing the American
Founding as as if it were a unique and
unprecedented experience every country
has the you know every country thinks
it's unique and every country has a
right to think it's unique because it is
and and people who you know spend their
time thinking about the uniqueness of
their own country they probably know
more about it than anybody looking from
the outside so everybody has the right
to do it and and it's healthy it's it's
healthy and in many ways it's good I'll
tell you what the problem is the problem
is the association with of the the
principles of the American Founding most
of which are I think are wonderful the
the Association of the principles of the
American Founding with universal reason
okay which I'm not saying you did but
many people do that is they claim that
what happened at the American Founding
or with the Declaration of Independence
and then sometimes also with the
Constitution is a kind of creation X
Neela which is which is very it's very
lock-in it's a very much lock it's very
much Rousseau to think that you could
just sit and think and by sitting and
thinking you could just come up with the
answers that are right for the whole
world I don't think anything like that
happen
I mean not even remotely like that so
let's take an American founder who is
not Burke he's not from the UK but he
agrees with me on this point I think
John Adams Adams wrote a three-volume
work defending the American Constitution
but the purpose of the work if you read
it is to first and foremost to show that
the English Constitution is the best
Constitution that was ever discovered by
human beings and the what's good about
the American Constitution is that it's
in all the important parts Adams argues
it is the English Constitution in other
words what he's saying and this is very
conservative he's not denying that there
is such a thing as universal rights or
that you know reason can somehow
approach it but he's saying that the way
that reason approaches it is through
trial and error through many centuries
of experience in fact a thousand years
of experience or more I think that
that's empirically simply true I think
the American Founding comes out of that
and if it weren't for the the English
tradition then we wouldn't have the
bicameral legislature the the the
unitary executive the separation of
powers the jury trial the the the
executive veto the almost the entire
thing all right with the with with some
wonderful exceptions I'm America goes
forward and says we don't have nobility
and we don't need nobility I think
that's wonderful a wonderful experiment
not English America also says the
English common law doesn't allow slavery
we do another experiment one that I find
despicable so America is a brilliant
thing it's a wonderful thing it might be
the best thing that there's been but the
mistake that people make I think it's a
very big mistake is is when you say it's
the basis of reason rather than the
cases of the anglo-american tradition
I'm sorry I should have I should have
mentioned the Dutch please if any of you
have not read the Dutch Declaration of
Independence of 1581 please do so
because you'll be shocked to see how
much of the American Declaration was
cribbed from there so I think it's
dangerous I think it's dangerous for
America even more than for the rest of
the world to think that that it's the
prized product that the product of pure
reason and and it's especially very
Roman it's especially very stoic and
that that I think is much worse than
then it's usually held to be but you've
create a straw man which is say that no
one has claimed that America is pure
reasoning you know jumping from
Madison's you know forehead like Zeus or
something it's it's always been this mix
but what we can't do which is I fear
that what is you're doing is you want to
get rid of reason to take sense that all
you have left is tradition and that
doesn't work it doesn't work for America
but more importantly doesn't work for
politics right because both examples
you've raised the decision to declare
independence and then the experiment
over slavery which also ends in a fight
both of those were questions of justice
and you've got to be able to figure out
how do you answer a question of justice
without having something to appeal to
because otherwise you don't know whether
your tradition is a good tradition or a
bad tradition and so my point is
tradition by itself is insufficient to
the point of allowing for nations to
exist and to be recognized and for
traditions within your own nation to be
going on their way as we wait for a
thousand years of empirical evidence
when they're patently unjust that
conversation is always going to be the
essence of politics it was it's not
American
that's just human and I think the United
States take sense that it it shows that
this the long development from the Greek
and the Romans up through English
constitutionalism to the point where
they could actually break with the
English Constitution remember john adams
also is one of the site that the first
kind of congress says we must appeal to
natural right as the basis for our claim
right it's there that it comes a point
where you have to make a claim to
justice and so how do we do that if it's
merely tradition recognizing that yes
that opens up this question that some
people are going to misuse that claim
but my point is it's worse to throw out
the baby with the bathwater okay what i
think i'm not going to respond in order
to well okay no just one sentence i
think it's unfair to the english
tradition to think that common lawyers
like Coke or Selden or Hale didn't know
what an appeal to justice was and that
American sort of just came okay
I'm saying just out of politics the way
the way you kind of done by appealing
over so overwhelming to tradition
because you you want to get rid of Locke
you just desperately want to get her a
lock and so much a lock I don't like but
you just want to expunge him so much
that as a result you've missed the whole
American tradition and and and that
becomes problematic in the same way to
to use to put it on someone else's
shoulders look I think Russell Kirk is
an extremely influential thinker I knew
him I like him he's you know he's very
important but he writes a whole book on
conservatism in America is essentially
not there except for John Adams and and
whom John C Calhoun can we make no
distinctions here
there's a problem when you when you try
to to merely stay with tradition okay
I'm glad you put that on Kirk I'm not
defending I'm not going to defend
Calhoun I'm not gonna do it how am I
gonna defend any of those slavers you
know but the distinction you gotta make
sure did that do if we if you don't make
that distinction that's the kinds of
problems you get into and I don't want
to see you get on that palm because you
made such a great argument attacking the
bad nationals
the bad international globalists look
just like you said I so much want to get
rid of Locke you've got my number I mean
boy does he make me mad all right but I
think I think the mirror image from the
front from your side might be that you
so much want to hold on to that that
you're not you're not willing to give
the common launch of the common law
tradition and this this this vast
earlier tradition it's due in terms of
what it discovered and the way it used
the law in order to try to reach justice
because because that was explicitly its
aim well I will grant that all right
will you grant the opposite yes
why so util you'll keep blocking the
tradition no I'll grant it I'm seriously
you want to talk about you mind if we
let your commentary to stand I think it
might come up with questions we should
go ahead chance yeah Steve Hayward
please
yeah microphones coming around if you're
called on please stand and wait for the
microphone Steve well I'm in heated
agreement with your basic basic thesis
but I do think someone should play
devil's advocate on one point that you
didn't bring up yet tonight and that is
that you're quite right to describe
liberal internationalism as representing
itself as idealism and we're gonna do
all these great good things for you but
I wonder at least in the European case
and Beyond it's really Hobbesian ism
it's really based on a fear of violent
death I mean I think we missed the
historical context that after to
cataclysmic civil global Wars Europe
suffers politically from post-traumatic
stress disorder that the Cold War
obscured for a long time and so
Europeans are taught to feel ashamed of
having pride in their nations I mean it
really is explicitly taught to Europeans
as my experience so a challenge for you
is this if you can get them to to be
reinvigorated to have some pride in
their nations in their nationalism how
do you reassure them that you know what
happened in Yugoslavia is not going to
spread around the rest of the continent
how are we going to how was Europe going
to avoid falling back into what we saw
in the first half of the 20th century I
don't feel that I'm in a position to
offer assurances
human beings are bad and they do bad
things and and and I don't think any any
theory that we're gonna come come up
with is just gonna simply solve that
having said that I I think you're
absolutely right that there
I like the post-traumatic stress
description of the West after World War
two I don't think it's necessarily even
just Europe and may even be America
somewhat I think you're exactly exactly
right that the the the rush to embrace
when I was when I was a kid I I remember
hearing John Lennon's Imagine and
thinking why would an awful and and and
I remember no as a kids thinking
thinking you know thank thank God it's
only some pop singer and then you know
later it turns out to be the political
theory of the major political parties
throughout and your psychological
interpretation is correct but that
doesn't that that's not a justification
for for a a terrible just awful content
political theory which has now been just
sort of circulating and doing tremendous
harm what I would like to say about
about the first and second world wars
which is it's not it's not
straightforward or simple I say it at
greater length and in the book and and
and I'm willing to discuss it I think
after World War one most observe
observers blamed World War one not on
nationalism but on imperialism on the
you may have even caught some of this in
in college although they don't teach it
very much anymore that the the the
English and French and the thirty years
before that had made this massive grab
to try to take over the globe to see who
was going to get to dominate the globe
and the Germans said well we don't want
to be left out of this how do we get in
by destroying France and taking over
part
Eastern Europe and so that was the old
version it didn't have anything to do
with nationalism it was all about
imperialism with regard to world war ii
i think the cases is even stronger or
even more more more more obvious hitler
is no nationalist except if you take his
word for it if you want to learn
political theory from hitler then then
you can reach all sorts of strange
conclusions but hitler is an imperialist
hitler was against the nation-state he
says this explicitly in mine camp first
of all is his goal is that Germany
should be mistress of the globe and Lord
of the earth that's no nationalism I've
never met a nationalist was anything
remotely like that kind of aspiration
and as far as the nation-state
he writes explicitly that the
nation-state is a corrupt idea like a
weak and sickened product of of English
and French minds and the whole goal of
he's his new biological Darwinian theory
is for Germany to sweep away the nation
states which have created division of
power a dispersion of power and to
concentrate it in the master race and
people if you can't see that that's that
that's a fundamentally different
political theory then I'm not going to
be able to reassure you but if you ask
me what should we be teaching European
kids and American kids first of all we
should be teaching them what I I take to
be the the the old and good biblical
lesson which is that God of heaven and
earth wanted Moses to give the law to
the Israelites and he gave borders and
told them that they're not allowed to
cross those borders the God of Israel is
the first God as far as we know in the
history of the world who gives borders
to his own people and tells them you get
punished if you cross them now that's
not just you know some some nice
historical piece of political theory
that they happen to never ever teach in
political theory programs as far as I
know in America it's actually an
essential thing early modern political
thought did catch that Selden knew it
grow
newett they when they were trying to
decide how international law was going
to set borders they were using the Bible
as an example they understood that
justice is based first first and
foremost in setting borders now you can
ask me why did those people then go why
do those countries then go out and abuse
Asians and Africans and and set up world
empires well I'll just tell you they did
it wrong what should we be teaching we
should be teaching first of all the
importance of boundaries for democracy
and for international justice and we
should be teaching that Empire is wrong
right now does that mean as Colin Colin
asks and I think this is a the right
question to be asking does that mean
that you you keep you can never
interfere I think that that would be
absurd does that mean that you don't
have a right to stand up and and and
accuse others of violating what you take
to be universal principles how could how
could you not have a right to say that
how could you not have a right to to
speak the truth and to call it out when
you see it after all aren't all those
other countries going to accuse America
and and what I suggest is is the
Americans kind of had a way of thinking
that through which is you have to relate
a principle which is true simply to a
practice which is a particular
circumstance prudence the virtue right
which is a conservative virtue so but
how do you make the distinction as to as
to in a circle how would you answer
without going to principle and then from
prints so so you need a universal of
course you know not a universal a
general right now in general is
something that is true you can call that
a universal give me a second I promise
not to take a very long but this is
important
decart believes in universals hume or
newton believes in generalizations which
are abstracted from experience right
that's not the same thing as is a
rational universal that you figured it
out and you now
declared to be true for all places in
all times the the anglo-american
tradition is not rationalist it's
empiricist and what I'm arguing for and
and I'm sorry Burke said it best I I
apologize that he happens to be English
but so was locked
the goal is from experience to learn
generalizations which we believe we hold
to be true but we but to have the
humility to understand that way we may
not be absolutely right right I mean
that is in in Newtons attack on
Descartes is exactly that is the
abstractions are our general and we can
hold them but we hold them only until we
see that that experience limits are
limits the applicability of the
applicability of the claim and what what
I find troubling about some Americans
and I can't not don't about you but I
finds is that like the French they don't
have sometimes they cross the line from
this is the best general relation
generalization that people have come up
with to this is a universal and it's
simply true if it's a universal and it's
simply true you're now putting yourself
in a place that sounds an awful lot like
those old Theological impure empires
that you are trying to get away from we
don't know things that are simply true
we know things that are this is let me
ask you this question is there anything
we can know to be true everything that
we know we know through our traditions
the things the word it is anything we
can know to be true simply without a
tradition there at all
there are we eagerly human you're asking
a scientific question which I don't know
I'm actually a practical common-sense
question
all men at all times ultimately an
abstract truth flickable to all men at
all times that all men are created equal
is that that's do you do you think
that's in general or universal interest
question to that question I promise to
answer this but I would like that I
think we were frustrated with us no I do
you really think that all men are
created equal is the proposition that
Kant is inarguable that reasonable
people can't disagree with I mean is
that yeah I think it's self-evident yeah
reasonably people can't disagree that
all men are created equal well they
can't disagree but some of them would be
wrong okay so look so we we've
definitely come to regular to a problem
so let me speak for for a moment for it
for a great English political theorist
and common lawyer John Selden he is the
the principal author of the petition of
right which is you could say is the
first draft of America's Bill of Rights
and he's a great thinker and he writes
exactly about this point and he says
when when thinkers like when thinkers
come in and want to say that there are
things that are simply known to reason
what example is there of anything he
asked of of any any conclusion of reason
that any philosopher at any stage in
history has come up with that there
haven't been other philosophers who are
adamantly opposed to and the correct
answer is none there is no such thing as
a philosophical declaration that major
flaw that major philosophers have not
disagreed with every single one they
disagree with so if over thousands of
years we can't find anything that
philosophers can't all simply agree with
then pushing a beautiful a beautiful
sentiment like all men are created equal
which is which
in a way it's a it's a distillation of a
certain of the biblical idea that all
men are created in God's image it's a
it's a beautiful thing it's useful in
many contexts it's important it I don't
want to take anything away from it
except for one thing
which is pushing it to the point that
you're gonna insist that you know this
to be true and therefore everybody else
should know that it's true and they're
just an error if they're not well that's
just that's it I was hoping that that we
conservatives have gotten had gotten
past that that's a dangerous place in my
opinion to be it's dangerous only if
it's on tempered by a prudence I think
don't you agree this creep sign thank
you yes thank you you say that we should
learn from our experiences in our
traditions but when we're distinguishing
between all of the different traditions
how do we know that the tradition that
we have in our Engel American tradition
is the best one and if the answer is
because it leads to human flourishing
and we've observed that how do we know
what human flourishing is thank you see
you Aristotle now go ahead look this is
going to end up this particular point is
going to end up simply going and going
in circles because the same dispute no
matter what level you take it to the
same dispute recurs there's some people
who think that you know what justice is
or what the absolute standards by which
to judge there's some some some thinkers
rationalists who think that somehow you
can just figure it out and in such a way
that that all properly thinking people
should come to the same conclusion and
then there are empiricists who think
that that's simply absurd and it's only
our art traditions what what our parents
taught us the principles that we have
and then us attempting to reason the
principles against one another and apply
them in experience which gives us an
answer to questions like what what is
justice alright so some people try to to
say you know I I don't want to put that
much weight on on on human reason so I'm
gonna put it on God alright then they'll
say so God revealed it so that solves
the problem for me but it doesn't really
solve the problem because it it because
if if you study Hebrew Scripture and you
look at the way that the laws are given
then you see that actually
God gives laws in iterations and there
is a process of discovery as God
discovers what human beings are like and
over that process the the the
determination of what laws are good and
proper emerges okay so this isn't I
don't want to say this is irresolvable
but this is one of those things that
philosophers simply can't agree about is
some of them think that they are smart
enough to figure out for all times in
places certain crucial truths that they
can then use to judge everything else
and then there are others of us the
empiricists who think you're kidding
yourself you got that from your parents
from your schools from your traditions
and and and also from examination
empirically of history that's where you
got that theory of what is just and what
is best how will you know you try it out
and you see what so I I just have a very
quick footnote which is you've only
given two alternatives and again it's a
straw man which is that it's not merely
it's not empiricism or pragmatism versus
rationalism there's another alternative
which i think is a dominant Western Way
of thinking philosophically which is the
kind of Greek Aristotelian toh mystic
way of thinking about human nature and
about justice and about all of these
questions that is actually also
extremely practical
and it's about relating principles and
politics in particular things that's a
very that's another way if they test
that says the third alternative as
opposed to the two you've laid out which
is precisely what I think is the one
that among other things informs the
Western tradition which culminates or at
least leads to American thought this
will be our final question
high blood and T curve I'd like to hear
your opinion kind of about really the
future of nationalism but in the
following context nationally that comes
from nation and I think there's a few
empirical facts today about all whatever
we oughta call them rich nations develop
relations you know they're all in
demographic collapse the reproduction
rates are you know the birth rates are
half of the reproduction rates we need
the demographic collapse there is a
replacement of the dominant ethnic or
religious group the share of the
minority in the newborn is much higher
than the share of the general
populations and in many societies this
groups have totally different cultural
affinity and loyalty to political
institutions to ideology to many of
those things labor participation in all
our nations is extremely low and it's
actually actually not comparable with
historical and participation because
when people had low labor especially in
the 50s man that this means that a lot
of mostly women stayed home raising
three four children today most of the
low rate of participation is you know
single unemployed unemployable elderly
population which is more and more
dependent on the government and the last
thing is we all have democracies which
with all the good things we can tell by
them from a career perspective of the
politicians extremely short term you
know job security means winning the next
election so in the context of those
facts how do you see the future of
nationalism as a political expression of
the future of our national destiny with
all
very important facts that are trends
that are very hard to change in the next
20 30 50 years thank you okay
I think this is a terrific question and
and really we should spend an evening on
these issues but let me let let me try
to focus on on one specific point which
is I think that the issues you're
raising are are I think the issues that
you're raising are best understood as
asking the following question what
donations need to do in order to
actually survive and you're hinting but
I'll say explicitly you don't have to
agree that what nations have to do to
actually survive in history is not the
same thing as the worldview that comes
out of of a certain set of abstract
principles about liberalism and
democracy that's one of the the points
that i try to make in in the book and i
I think much more weight needs to be put
onto it how can a political theory how
can a way of understanding the politics
of one nation or of many nations how can
it possibly be the best political theory
or the right political theory if an
experience we see that what happens is
that it leads to demographic collapse
and that the countries are then not some
nations are then not sustainable
right now I don't I don't associate the
American Founding with John Locke and
liberalism exclusively although I admit
that Locke was there and he's important
in some documents but no no but FFX I
actually the evil seed is there that's
saying a bit much I would say that it's
that it's that's immensely foolish to
take an abstraction from the market
which is good at describing economic
functions and turn it into a theory of
all politics it's just a terrible theory
so as long as it's limited to to
economics and other areas were
empirically it's useful then I'm fine
with it but this gentleman has just
pointed to
I don't know doesn't this worry you 40%
of children are born outside of marriage
in the United States right now or and
and and rising in Europe it's it's even
worse the population the fertility in
the United States was it just just
announced that it dropped to one point
seven six and and will probably continue
to drop just as it does across Europe so
I live in Israel Israel is one of the
only democratic countries where the
where the birth rate is going up and I'm
not saying that we've solved all the
problems in the world we sure haven't
but please let's focus on this Americans
and many other you and many European
countries would be really happy if their
fertility rate were going up instead of
down
now I'm not saying that I know exactly
how to solve this problem but I do have
a pretty good idea of where it comes
from if you try to turn political theory
into to reduce it to a theory of
individuals taking on obligations
strictly on the basis of consent and
reaching the decision as to what to
consent to strictly on the basis of
their reason if you if you teach that to
generation after generation for for a
hundred years and you say there's no
Bible in the schools and there's no
counterweight to it there's no source
for for any kind of obligation other
than your own consent well guess what
two people who want to stay married will
not be able to stay married because they
haven't been given the tools to do it
Locke doesn't give people the tools to
stay married if they want to be married
and he doesn't give them the tools to
understand why they should have children
if you
it just becomes too scary to have
children I know I have I have children
and they're scared you can say and
they're having post-traumatic stress
syndrome from growing up with your own
that may also be part of it I think this
gentleman I don't know if you agree but
I I think he's touching on the key
factor are we going to simply say we
know we have the universal truth for all
time
or are we willing empirically to correct
it saying we're willing to empirically
correct it does not in any way take away
from the greatness of the American
Founding or the American nation but it's
realistic and it's important if you want
America to have a future so so the key
to or a demographic destiny is having a
self-identity right that's what Israel
has and that's why I think it's so the
demographic destiny is to go back to
studying the Bible which is the source
for many of the traditions which have
dissipated in America because after
World War two
right up until world well grant you that
point the point I was gonna get slightly
a fraud but but from from generally
speaking I would grant the point you
made but my point and the reason I bring
this up is that part of getting American
figured out as a nation is for Americans
to rediscover what it means which is why
these are crucially important
conversations to have and I think we
can't merely shunt that aside and turn
America into merely rationalism we want
them to love their country and loving
their country means it what's the
principle what's the thing what's the
end what's the good for which it stands
that's why I think this is important to
think through and and I think that too
merely shunted aside his locking ISM I
think misses what America is and I think
that at least he here has to be the
heart of what conservatism is about
okay yeah go ahead I didn't say that
America was locking ISM I know some
people do I don't think it's
historically true and I think that if it
were historically true Americans should
be willing to make some adjustments
because it's not all of who they are and
I think on that we we really do agree
that John Locke is not all of who
America is and learning about what
America is I think it has to involve
Locke but it also has to involve the
Bible and also has to involve the common
law by the time you do that you might be
able to get to an answer to to this
gentleman's question about how Americans
could could have a future even for
obvious if we had a fourth person up
here who was a liberal global governance
advocate you would see that we agree on
fundamentals the three of us do you know
it's the thing that keeps coming up is
for most American nationalists it's
important to understand in what way it's
America in other words it's not just the
nationalism it's the Americanism of it
and that's where we keep getting this
debate but I mean just to sort of stick
up for your arm on this point it's not
as if the main problem the last 25 years
has been a an excessive American sense
of nationhood I mean I do America is an
idea but it's also a place and if
politicians from either parties forget
that when they're pursuing trade
policies foreign policies immigration
policies if they forget that they are
there to represent the interests of US
citizens the voters will remind them and
that's where that's where I think we
right now actually so I mean in a way
this is your arms' point and Daniel
Webster said it the last you know the
last logic of Kings is also our last
logic we must survive you know well I
encourage everyone to visit Claremont
org and Hillsdale dot e-d-u for more
lectures on these things and writings
and thank you all for coming and thank
you
[Applause]